there's a lot of international mail
that flows to a small nation in western
africa
the mail is addressed to an address that
should be right here
along this main street but i asked my
friend to go there
and check it out and he didn't find
anything looking for any brush
i'm going to say that any groceries
doesn't exist instead the mail that is
addressed to go here
is actually brought to a building down
the road
right here right yeah this building is
where all
lrsc airfields are imported from the
building that doesn't exist
from there the mail is scanned and sent
electronically
thousands of miles away to a nondescript
office building
outside of washington dc it's actually
right near my house in northern virginia
henry check out this random building
does this building look super boring to
you
oh this building is right near our house
i guess i expected something a little
bit more
interesting this process
is a part of a secretive web of
corporate secrecy it's a web that is
built off of years of strange
connections between the united states
and the country of liberia a nation
invented by
a group of americans here in virginia
this is how the u.s stashed its secrets
off the coast of west africa
in this building there is a bunch of
mail that comes from
a little country in west africa and it
gets sent to
this building near our house does that
seem kind of weird to you
yes what did they do with it
that's what i want to figure out here
so let's say i want to start an
international corporation and start
doing business abroad
i live here in the united states so
naturally i would want to start my
company here in the u.s
but when i ask the internet how to do
this i get a bunch of
ads that look like this
even though my office would be here in
washington dc in the united states
the internet is telling me that on paper
i should set up my corporation
in one of these random small countries
around the world
places like the british virgin islands
or mauritius or belize
gibraltar malta the seychelles islands
wait the seychelles
like that tiny island nation in the
middle of the indian ocean
that has like less than 100 000 people
it's like 40 hours of flying to get
there why would i want to set up my
business
in the seychelles
here's why if i set up my corporation on
paper
in the british virgin islands or the
seychelles suddenly
i actually don't have to pay very much
taxes if any at all my new corporation
now won't have to actually obey any of
the
corporate laws here in the united states
which require you to
publish all sorts of information about
your finances
about your corporation to the public
record if my corporation is in the
seychelles
i don't have to do any of that this is
actually starting to seem like a pretty
attractive option
these tiny nations have set up their
laws to
attract big corporations for this very
purpose to set up on paper
in their country so that the government
can make a little bit of money off of
the little taxes they receive and any of
the registration fees and dues
and it's not just corporations the same
concept applies to shipping vessels
these are big barges that make our world
economy run and they spend most of their
time
in water that belongs to no country and
yet they still have to follow the rules
of the country whose flag they fly where
they're registered
and so if you register to a country that
has very low taxes and
no laws around how you need to treat
your employees on the boat and what
safety regulations you need to follow
then those are the rules you need to
follow when you're out on the high c
so the modern global economy turns out
to be
a race to the bottom corporations and
shipping vessels
registering themselves to whatever
country will give them the least amount
of accountability
and transparency we call these havens
tax havens or shelters and this isn't
just like shady
criminal corporations most corporations
that you
interact with on a daily basis have
loads of subsidiaries in
far away tax havens that they have set
up to escape
transparency and accountability
okay but back to me and my corporation
that i theoretically want to sign up
if i want to set up in the seychelles or
the british virgin islands
this is actually kind of complicated how
do i navigate all the laws and the
paperwork
ask the internet and when i ask the
internet i get a bunch of ads
these are ads of companies who are
dedicated
to helping corporations set up in these
offshore jurisdictions and these tax
havens
so if i want to set up the british
virgin islands i could choose
a bunch of different companies to help
me get that paperwork done
and then while i actually do my business
back here in washington dc
they help manage all the taxes and the
requirements and all the little things i
need to do
to upkeep my little facade of having a
company
in this place even though i actually
don't okay so here's where this gets
weird
we're talking about tax havens and
offshore jurisdictions and all this
stuff let's get back to liberia
which liberia is one of these tax havens
it's a place that has structured its
laws to attract
foreign corporations and shipping
vessels to register with them
so that they can make a little money off
of those dues and taxes
when i go to start my corporation in
liberia i don't get a bunch of ads for
middlemen who want to help me set up my
new liberian corporation
instead i'm funneled to one company this
one and this company boasts that it has
the exclusive right to handle
all companies that want to register
their corporation or
ship in liberia this is the company
whose building is near my house
and on the surface it just looks like
another middleman paper pusher super
boring but you peek under the surface
and there's something way bigger going
on here
not just a corporation running away from
taxes and accountability but instead
this is a symbol of how the us projects
its power in the 21st century
and how it uses other countries to hide
its secrets
quick pause for a second this story is
crazy and it's about to get even more
crazy
the whole reason i'm going down this
rabbit hole that i started to look into
this liberia thing
is because of a phone call i had i was
driving north up to massachusetts a
couple months ago many of you may have
seen the videos from that trip and i was
on the phone
with my friend ben over at foley foley's
the
company who makes my desk and the chair
i'm sitting on ben and i got chatting i
just announced that i
the borders was canceled and i was sort
of moving on to new projects and he was
like what stories do you want to
make and like can can we support your
stories
i was like yes but like anything that
has to do with like the global economy
which is something i'm sort of
interested in is like i'm gonna go deep
and i'm gonna
uncover crazy stuff and like your
company you know who does business in
the global economy
and he was like do it like i want to see
like what storytelling you can do and we
want to support that for context here
fully is a b
corp a b corp is a type of corporation
that isn't just the standard
profit-seeking company
instead they make major efforts to be
transparent
to be socially impactful in a positive
way
to be um accountable and to be
sustainable
that's rare that's a rare thing foley
does not claim to be
perfect all they say is that they're
making a major effort
to be the type of corporation that
leaves a positive impact
on the people who use the product but
also the people who interact with
the production and to leave a positive
impact on the globe while doing so
and that's why they're supporting this
video today is because they care about
this sort of thing
and they want to always be pushing the
limit on
how we think about business and how we
think about
the impact of corporations in the world
and i respect that it's so rare
among companies these days and so i love
foley for that reason
oh and they make amazing products like
that's also a giant part of this
so my desk a lot of the stuff in our
studio is
fully stuff they sell really high
quality products
desks and chairs and all sorts of
products that make you more active and
just improve your relationship with work
they don't want you to buy these
products unless you actually need them
but there's a lot of people these days
who tend to need a new work from home
set up given the times we're in
and so they are running a sale on their
site for the whole month of november
which is a few days left in that sale
these are not just your standard desks
these are an investment in
a product that will last you a very long
time they're solid
they're well built go on to the foley
site check out their products see if
there's anything there that you need
right now
but the major message here is foley
wants you to be thoughtful about the
stuff that you buy
knowing that it's often a part of a much
larger system thank you foley for
supporting this video
let's get back to the story of liberia
and what the heck is happening in
liberia
it gets pretty nuts from here
what's the deal why does this one random
building
in virginia run a
network of corporate secrecy in the
country of liberia like it's so weird
and as soon as you start to go down this
rabbit hole
it just gets weirder and the short
answer here is that
the united states of america literally
invented the country of liberia back in
the 1800s
here in the united states the biggest
most important debate
was over slavery this issue led the
country to almost
imploding on itself in a bloody civil
war during this debate
there emerged three major camps with the
slavery issue
one were the abolitionists the people
who were like dude this is wrong
let's reform our country to be done with
this
terrible thing we've done and then of
course there were the people on the
pro-slavery side who were
often had a financial incentive to keep
slavery alive
with their plantations and their
businesses but then there was this third
camp in the middle
who were on paper against slavery they
wanted to get rid of slavery it was a
bad thing but they didn't really want
the freed black americans to integrate
into american society
as this debate raged on there were some
americans
here in virginia who came up with a
solution what if
we gave the option to enslaved people
who had been
freed to go to africa where their
ancestors came from
we could ship them back we could buy a
piece of land and they would all
flock to the boats to go back to africa
was the thinking here the
quasi-abolitionists
kind of liked this because they're like
oh yeah we can get the moral buzz out of
being against slavery
but we don't have to deal with the
complicated consequences
of our actions to reintegrate these
people into our society and then of
course
the slave owners liked this too because
it meant that any freed black americans
could be
shipped away so they wouldn't foment
rebellion among those enslaved people
who were still working on plantations
so there was this strange alignment
between these quasi-abolitionists and
these slave owners and they started
their own organization
so this organization that was based here
in virginia
bought a piece of land in western africa
with money from their supporters and
from the us government
and they started sending ships full of
black people to this land to create a
settlement
that they called liberia or land of the
free
they named the capital monrovia after
president james monroe
who was a fierce supporter of this
effort to send away
free black americans
okay so at this point i'm sure you're
kind of like wait a minute
what was this curveball we went from
talking about the seychelles
and tax havens to talking about how a
bunch of virginians started
sending freed black americans to a piece
of land in africa that they bought
and this is where these two come
together soon
the liberians declare independence
liberian locals the ones who had come
from the united states that
started to take power and actually be
the leaders of the country they actually
started
to enact slavery of their own in their
society just like they had seen
in the united states but behind the
scenes of all of this
the us political interests that started
this whole thing
remained they had an actual building
there and they were actually
calling the shots so liberia was
independent
on paper but in reality the us
had as much influence as ever in their
little colony in africa
and that influence became really useful
a hundred years later
so it's 100 years later the us just got
out of world war ii
and you have this guy this guy was the
secretary of state
for the us which is like the foreign
minister he became a
u.s representative at the u.n and he was
out on a diplomatic tour that brought
him to liberia
while in liberia this little african
nation that was created by
the united states and still had deep
ties to the united states
he looked at the deep sea port that the
u.s had created during world war ii
and his wheels started turning he
returned to the united states
and quickly stepped down from his role
as a diplomat
harry truman like really wanted him to
stick around as a diplomat
but he had actually a very strong reason
to leave
truman said that he had an earnest
insistence to go do his own thing
this guy was a diplomat but he was also
a businessman and what he saw during his
visit to liberia
revealed the business opportunity that
he just could not
leave on the table so over the next year
this ex-secretary of state
started scheming with the librarian
government and in september 1947
he came out and announced that he a
private american citizen
had made a deal with the liberian
government he created
a company an american-based company
based here in virginia
that was to be the exclusive middleman
between any international corporation
and the government of liberia basically
if anyone wanted to set up their
corporation in liberia
they would have to go through this guy
and his new company he helped the
liberian government craft
laws that would make it very attractive
for people
to put the liberian flag on their ship
or
on their company and over the next few
years this gained
major traction at this time any shipping
vessel
that had the american flag or the soviet
flag
would be subject to a bunch of trade
barriers that were starting to go up as
a part of this like cold war between the
us and soviets
this ex-secretary of state and his new
company would go around and say hey put
the liberian flag on your ship
and now you can trade with whoever the
hell you want the liberian registry
exploded
and now you had ships flying the
liberian flag not having to pay barely
any taxes and not having to obey
any laws from the united states and
being able to trade with whomever they
want
because liberia was officially neutral
in the cold war the liberian registry
was born
and it was thriving
so in recent decades the number of ships
that register under the liberian flag
who never stepped foot in liberia by the
way
but have their flag on their ship has
grown and has become
the second most common flag on
international ships in the world only
second to panama
meanwhile the company here in virginia
who has a monopoly over this
registry is getting super rich and
they're giving some of those riches to
the liberian government
but what the liberian government does
with that money is actually
probably the ugliest underbelly of this
whole story
so by the late 90s this company's doing
great liberia's
taking in a bunch of money from all of
the ships registering under their flag
but then
this guy charles taylor becomes the
president
how can i help you on liberian shipping
registries it's a long time since i've
been looking at them
what has the registry allowed the
government of liberia
to do that it wouldn't be able to do
otherwise it was one of the most
consistent
dependable sources of revenue for the
liberian government that was important
particularly in the charles taylor
period when it was civil war
in in liberia and there were no other
sources of revenue
it was a war economy he
starts taking the money that's coming in
from all these ship and corporation
registries
but not just to fight these wars he goes
on to commit some of the most egregious
crimes the world has ever seen
as the one myself that investigated the
shipping registry
we found documented exposed that the
shipping registry
that its revenues were being diverted to
purchase arms and ammunition in
violation of u.n sanctions
and yet the corporations and ships that
fly the liberian flag
don't even have to think about this
stuff they don't step foot in liberia
they've never met charles taylor or any
of his people
they just go about doing their thing and
doing all of their business
through a nondescript office
right near my house where a company is
getting
very rich using liberia as
the facade but really everything is
happening
right here the money is being made right
here and a little bit of that
is being sent to liberia and liberia is
using it to do terrible things
charles taylor eventually goes to the
international court of justice and
gets indicted on a million really
horrible counts goes to joe for the rest
of his life
but the registry that helped fund
his horrible rise remains
and remains as a mechanism
for helping many corporations around the
world hide their secrets
and evade accountability and this
connection between these
two unlikely places retains a similar
purpose
as its original one way back in the
1800s when with the support of the u.s
government
private interests sent away their
secrets
and their guilt to a far away place and
that hasn't really stopped happening
today with the blessing of the u.s
government corporations
continue to deposit their secrets in
this same
faraway place far away from any real
accountability
thank you all for watching this video
this is the type of video that i want to
do more of
a video like this takes longer takes
more time because it's a lot more
research it's more interviews
i'm actually diving way deeper into
these stories than
than the typical explainer you see on
this channel and that's what i want to
do
starting in 2021 i want to start doing
more stories like this
my patrons make that possible and brands
like fully who
care about this sort of thing make that
possible as well so
i am hoping that more and more i'll be
able to
do deep dive stories like this and then
when travel opens up i want to be able
to travel
and go do deep dive stuff like i used to
do it at vox
um thank you all for watching and i've
got some more good stuff coming
and i hope you are having a wonderful
november and i'll
see you soon